before we we started talking you were
checking out there's a guitar there
there's a guitar back there and i know
that you're a very
uh you're a very well-trained jazz
musician that's fair to say you actually
you know your stuff i i studied it
very hard in high school and when i was
you know
trying to figure out what i was going to
do in my life music was
one of the options that i was
considering but
you know being such an aficionado of the
music
and really a student of it and
probably mixed with some amount of
uh neuroses and and a
lack of confidence in that area i kind
of didn't want to pursue it because i
just knew what shedding
as a musician was going to be to get to
where i wanted to get
you know when my musical heroes and
miles and charlie parker and cannonball
adeline like i'm
shooting like that going i'm going to
have to really dedicate
my entire life to this focus
and it was you know music is
kind of elusive to a brain that doesn't
like get math
sometimes you know what i mean there's a
lot of structure in it that
i would sometimes just go into a fog i
would have a great ear had a great ear
could always
fake my way around stuff but i was like
if i'm going to really have to dig into
theory
the amount of time i'm going to have to
take i think i'm just going to be an
actor
i think you made it i think you made a
good choice first of all it's worked out
pretty well
it's i'm doing all right yeah you're
doing kind of okay
um but do you ever do you play music now
do you ever
do you play jazz in your in your free
time i do
i do i started to you know pick up the
bass a few years ago
and it's great to just i mean they're
beautiful right it's great to just have
them sitting around
understand you have 20 30 minutes just
pick it up and like
get into it so i've been doing that uh a
lot
do you do vocal stuff do you ever do
vocal jazz stuff i haven't i mean i sing
just to mess around but that's
when i was uh in high school that's
basically what we did that was mainly
one of the things i did i had
scholarships i was fortunate enough to
get scholarships to
uh attend universities and study vocal
jazz and jazz that was going to be my
my metier i have never studied uh vocal
jazz in any way
but it's one of those things i know that
i would master immediately
you i get that from you you have vocal
jazz vibes coming off of you
thank you in waves i've never been more
serious about anything in my life
i just i i and i don't mean i know it
sounds arrogant what i'm saying
oh it does it's just a statement of fact
that i can just yeah i can just touch
you could just give me
uh you know is that piano tuned i mean
you hit a g
or give you just a can you give me a g
you know give me a g
over there and i'm going to give you
thank you very much just give me a g
oh
i thought there was a pinterest i knew
there was a little more i knew there was
more that was more gas
than anything else yeah yeah so
that's just something i don't like to
talk about a lot but
i could see what
i think it's time to wrap this up
this is that moment that we foresaw i
really enjoyed watching your face during
that [ __ ]
[Laughter]
it was amazing it was a return to your
boogie night's performance you looked
completely lost and just
been filming my soul
i was bereft of spirit at that moment
you